yep oh yeah if you blink you might miss
you gotta click it or ticket you gotta
go get together before it's gone hang on
so alright start again James Corden
tries to keep up with chance the rapper
on another epic installment of carpool
karaoke during the Late Late Show I'm
gonna let you finish but I had the
greatest shout outs of the night 26 year
old rapper hit the street with the
late-night host during at Tuesday's
episode where he helped James with a bit
more than just being his carpool buddy
chance actually helped him rap all day
long
and the pair crushed it it comes at you
fast
[Music]
[Applause]
chance also shared a bit more than his
amazing vocals he also revealed his
friendships with jay-z and former
President Barack Obama have a lot in
common
well yeah I have a no so I don't have
this I don't have any number for him but
I have a number for him I have a person
that I could call that will say okay
I'll I'll have him call you that's the
same the same way with jay-z jay-z and
brocco bomber they're very similar both
of them have like an assistant that you
have to call and then you get a call
from a private number and it's either
jay-z or Barack Obama on the phone I
never know which one it is calling I get
the that callback makes perfect sense it
makes 100% sense and get this chance
hates vegetables so James made a meet
some blindfolded of course it does not
like vegetables number one have any
mouth what do you think that might be
what this feels like plastic I obviously
don't eat vegetables at all what do you
think that's like oh this is a carrot it
is very good boy dear God how is that
it's so curl yeah everything's great man
has been awesome
[Music]